>> Dana: I ALMOST FORGOT THIS
WAS ME.
CHICAGO MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT HAS
MADE HER CITY FURIOUS AND FOR A
GOOD REASON.
SHE IS COVERING UP CRIME.
AN ELECTION RACE TAMMY BY THE
DECISION TO BLOCK THE PUBLIC
FROM BEING ABLE TO MONITOR THE
POLICE SCANNERS BY MOVING TO
COMMUNICATIONS TO ENCRYPTED
CHANNELS.
MULTIPLE MEDIA OUTLETS CALLING
THE MAYOR AND ACCUSING HER OF
PUSHING CENSORSHIP IN THE PUREST
FORM EDIT ADD ADDING THIS, "THE
MAYOR TO RESTRICT SCANNER
CHANNELS TO KEEP YOU COME WITH
THE VIEWERS AND THE READERS
INFORMED.
AND RENDER IT MORE DIFFICULT TO
HOLD THE GOVERNMENT AND ITS
PERSONNEL ACCOUNTABLE.
BUT LORI LIGHTFOOT SAID IT WILL
MAKE THE POLICE SAFER.
>> BUT IS ABOUT OFFICER SAFETY.
IT IS UNENCRYPTED AND ACCESS,
THERE IS NO WAY TO CONTROL
CRIMINALS WHO ARE ALSO GOING TO
GET ACCESS, LISTENING IN, AND
THEIR CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR IN
RESPONSE TO THE INFORMATION THAT
IS BEING COMMUNICATED.
>> Dana: SO THIS WAS
IMPOSSIBLE WITH PREVIOUS
TECHNOLOGY, KATIE.
IT REMINDS ME WHEN THE FAA TRIED
TO PREVENT DRONES FROM COVERING
THE HAITIAN MIGRANTS UNDER THE
BRIDGE AND TAXES.
THEY CALLED THEM OUT ON IT AND
THEY HAD TO BACK DOWN BECAUSE
CLEARLY A FIRST AMENDMENT
VIOLATION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WILL HAPPEN
HERE?
>> THE BIGGEST PICTURE IS IF YOU
WANT TO PROTECT POLICE OFFICERS,
LORI LIGHTFOOT WOULD PUT
PRESSURE ON PROSECUTORS TO KEEP
THE CRIMINALS OFF THE STREETS
BUT THE COPS ARE ENCOUNTERING
THE SAME PEOPLE OVER AND OVER
AGAIN, THE SAME NEIGHBORHOODS
COME WITH COMMITTING THE SAME
CRIMES AND YET STILL BEING LET
OUT OF JAIL.
IN TERMS OF THE POLICE TRAFFIC
ENDEMIC SCANNERS, IT ISSUED BY
PEOPLE TO LISTEN AND IF THERE IS
A SHOOTING OR HIGH SPEED CHASE,Y
KNOW WHERE IT IS AND THEY CAN
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES NOT TO GO IN CERTAIN
AREAS, ESPECIALLY PEOPLE WHO
DEAL WITH THIS ALL THE TIME.
SO CAN I DO THINK IT IS ABOUT
HER TO CONTROL A NARRATIVE AHEAD
OF THE ELECTION.
SHE DOESN'T WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW
WHAT IS GOING ON AND PEOPLE CAN
GO TO THE SOURCE WHEN
OUT-OF-CONTROL THINGS ARE IN
CHICAGO UNDER HER LEADERSHIP
WHICH SHE THINKS IS JUST FINE.
>> Dana: WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
HER TRYING TO DO THIS?
DO YOU THINK IT IS ABOUT
POLICING?
>> Greg: NO, LIKE KATIE SAID,
THIS IS NOT THE PRIORITY IF YOU
CARE ABOUT POLICE SAFETY.
ALTHOUGH I DO KIND OF UNDERSTAND
IT BECAUSE SCANNERS COME I NEVER
CALL 911.
I DON'T WANT TO END UP ON A
SCANNER BECAUSE THAT WILL BE ON
TMZ AND SOMETHING EMBARRASSMENT,
"I FELL ON THE BATHTUB AND I
HAVE TO GO TO THE E.R."
GOD KNOWS WHAT HAPPENS THERE
NEVER STAYS THEY ARE, YOU KNOW.
ONE OF THOSE THINGS WHERE CRIME
REPORTING IS CONSIDERED SCAB
JOURNALISM.
YOU ARE CROSSING THE PICKET LINE
TO REPORT ON THE STORY THAT
OTHER JOURNALISTS STRIKE
AGAINST.
AND SHE'S ALWAYS REFLECTED THIS
THAT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT CRIME,
IT IS LIKE YOU ARE BETRAYING HER
IF YOU DO.
AND MEANWHILE, IF YOU TALK TO
ANYBODY IN THE MEDIA GENERALLY
TWO YEARS AGO OR THREE YEARS
AGO, EVERY CRIME STORY IS A
LOCAL STORY.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT?
THERE IS A PERSON THAT USED TO
SAY THAT AND IN D.C.
IT IS A LOCAL STORY.
ALL OF THOSE LOCAL STORIES ADDED
UP TO ONE NATIONAL STORY A
RAGING CRIME EPIDEMIC.
AND I THINK IT IS UNCOMFORTABLE
FOR PEOPLE LIKE LORI LIGHTFOOT
AND OTHERS TO APPROACH THIS
TOPIC BECAUSE OF THEIR
CULPABILITY AND NEVER COVERING
IT, NEVER ADDRESSING IT, AND
ALSO SUPPORTING SUCH PROGRESSIVE
POLICIES AS NO CASH BAIL AND
SENTENCING DIRECTLY LINKED TO
WHAT WE ARE SEEING RIGHT NOW.
THE JOURNALISTIC SCANDAL IS
BIGGER THAN THE POLITICAL
SCANDAL BECAUSE IT IS NOT A
VICTIMLESS CRIME, ESPECIALLY
WHEN THEY DEVOTE THOUSANDS OF
INCHES TO VIOLENT FAR RIGHT
PARENTS.
THERE IS JUST PEOPLE DYING
EVERYWHERE.
FINALLY, "THE WASHINGTON POST"
IS ACTUALLY DOING EXPOSES ON
MURDERS, WHICH IS LIKE, NOW IT'S
OKAY?
WHAT MADE IT DIFFERENT?
>> Dana: THE NO CASH BAIL,
THAT WILL ACTUALLY BE A
STATEWIDE POLICY IN ILLINOIS
STARTING JANUARY 1ST BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED THAT LITTLE
DEADLY INTO LAW.
>> Jesse: LOOK WHAT HAPPENED
TO THE REST OF THE COUNTRY IF WE
WANT TO GO DOWN THAT ROAD.
>> Dana: STATEWIDE.
>> Jesse: I SPOKE TO A FORMER
COP AND HE SAID BACK IN THE DAY,
THEY ARE BETTER RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE POLICE DEPARTMENTS
AND LOCAL MEDIA.
THE LOCAL MEDIA WOULD HONOR
POLICE REQUEST OR LOW BACK
INFORMATION AND BE ABLE TO HELP
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
OR SOMETIMES THEY WOULD WANT
PEOPLE TO GET THAT OUT THERE AND
WARNED THE PUBLIC BUT HE SAID
NOW, IT HAS CHANGED.
A LOT OF TIMES THE POLICE WILL
COME UP ON THE SCENE AND TRY TO
FILM COPS AND CATCH THEM IN A
BAD MOMENT AND MAKE THEM LOOK
BAD, BLOW UP A RACIAL SCANDAL.
THEY DON'T COOPERATE LIKE THEY
USED TO.
AND I WOULD IS SENSATIONAL HERE
THEY ARE TRYING TO SELL A
PRODUCT, WE DO TOO, GETTING
RATINGS TO GET TO THE SCENE
FIRST.
BUT --
>> Greg: DETAILS, JESSE.
>> Jesse: YOU WOULD RATHER BE
RIGHT THAN FIRST.
>> Greg: YES.
>> Jesse: YOU SAY THAT ALL THE
TIME ALTHOUGH YOU ARE NEITHER.
THERE IS A LITTLE MORE NUANCED
TO THE STORY.
YOU KNOW ME, MR. NUANCE.
THERE IS A GRAY AREA.
>> Greg: VERY GOOD.
>> Jesse: THANK YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jessica: I THINK THEY ARE
ADEPTLY GREAT AREAS TO THE
SPIRIT IT SEEMS LIKE OTHER
CITIES HAVE DONE THIS, DENVER
DESERT, LOUISVILLE DOES IT BUT
THE DIFFERENCE IS CHICAGO
ALDERMAN BROUGHT THIS UP, THEY
DON'T RUN ON A DELAY
SYSTEM.
SO YOU COULD HAVE THE ENCRYPTED
SOFTWARE OR WHATEVER IT IS TO
READ THIS AND REGULAR PEOPLE
COULD GET THOSE.
THERE COULD BE NEIGHBORHOOD
INITIATIVE TO MAKE SURE
PARTICULARLY BAD NEIGHBORHOODS A
PROJECT HAS A SYSTEM WHEN THEY
COULD LISTEN AND TO WHAT IS
GOING ON BECAUSE THERE IS THIS
CRAZY CASE WHERE 40 SHOTS WENT
OFF AND NOBODY KNEW WHAT WAS
GOING ON IN THE AREA.
THEY WOULD HAVE TYPICALLY RELIED
ON RADIO TRANSMISSIONS AND NOW
THEY CAN'T.
IT SEEMS A WAY TO FIND A HAPPY
MEDIUM.
IF YOU DON'T THINK TO PROTECT
POLICE OFFICERS BUT THE MEDIA
BEING A PART OF THIS, SOMETIMES
THEY EXPLOIT THE SITUATION TO
MAKE SURE THEY CAN BE FIRST WITH
LITTLE NUANCE.
YOU CAN GET THERE.
BUT I DON'T THINK A CITY LIKE
DENVER WOULD BE DOING THIS IF IT
WAS SOMETH